I'm Destin from Huntsville Alabama. This is Sadie and Spotsy. So here's my question.
On the International Space Station, if you're free falling in one position,
without touching anything, with no spin, and you have no airflow over you,
is it possible to wiggle in such a way that you're able to rotate to a different
angular position and then stop without violating the conservation of
angular momentum? On Smarter Every Day we demonstrated this with a high speed camera and a cat,
who is a non holonomic system and can do this by extending his legs, arching his back
and twisting in a very specific pattern. So can humans do this on orbit? I'd love to see
a video demonstration on the International Space Station, and explain to me if your
brain had to figure it out or if you just instantly knew how to do this. Anyway,
thank you for helping us get Smarter Every Day on orbit, and uh.. you want to say hey to the
astronauts?
- Hey.
- Thank you. We look up to you guys.
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.